[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
дорогие друзья вот мы приехали в этот
исторический славный город стамбул где у
нас будет проходить не везет тем
следующие пять дней сегодня нулевой день
мы встречаемся знакомимся у нас семьи
сегодня день нетворкинга и приятного
времяпровождения сзади меня стоит яхта
на котором мы сейчас пойдем паба створу
делать экскурсию там у нас ждет нас ждет
ужин знакомства нетворкинге так далее мы
хотим чтобы у всех осталось приятное
впечатление от первого дня потому что
следующие пять дней мы будем работать
как угорелый поэтому до
нашего буткемпа сегодня нулевой день
всем желаю успехов удачи и много-много
трудолюбия у нас переде тяжелые трудные
гей но все они посвящены учебе или
прокачки самого себя так яхта нас ждет
ребята уже на верхней палубе до встречи
там
[аплодисменты]
сегодня у нас 0 де нашего инвест
буткемпа и мы проводим сегодня network и
мелком потери
научиться инвестировать нужно как
минимум для двух вещей во-первых это
расширяет кругозор и помогает развивать
ваш бизнес ну что вы на него начинаете
смотреть за глобальной картинки
helicopter view космические масштабы вы
перестаете бояться за выходить на другие
страны
конкурировать большими игроками и а
может быть вы наоборот найдете там
каких-то новых партнеров этому
инвестиции это расширение кругозора 1
вторую это безопасность вашей семьи
потому что бизнес к сожалению как
показывает ситуация в украине он в
какой-то момент существует а потом может
быть у него возникает какие-то
совершенно неконтролируемый вами события
и та подушка безопасности которые вы
создаете для себя для своей семьи виде и
покупки недвижимости за рубежом
формирование какой танец и на профиль
это это классная очень успокаивающая но
это безопасность меня зовут норман тоска
баев мне 30 лет я родом из караганды
занимаясь бизнесом больше 12 лет
население у меня 6 компаний мы работаем
в 11 странах мира меня зовут эльдар то
лишь я приехал из города дубай живую
работаю там на рынке недвижимости
приехал в стамбул nine west меня зовут
ирина ким я приехала из лондона
четырнадцатом году я продала свой бизнес
занимаю сейчас инвестициями в финансовый
рынок в стартапы и в криптовалюте доброе
утро меня зовут сол лет cf я приехал из
города как стал main визбор будка
который проходит стамбуле занимаясь
строительством городе как считал
казахстане и а также у меня бизнес дубай
автомобильный меня зовут эрик
яз октябре казахстан
я представляю группу компаний назначить
и это строительство как промышленные
такие гражданские также есть компании с
деятельности фэнси g
финансы полиграфия приехал на инвест
boot camp чтобы получить знаниям ну и
соответственно
новые знакомства непосредственно
знакомства смогу аркадьевичем с учетом
того что внешность бизнесах я должен
думать о седьмом а также я тех шести
которые у меня есть в портфеле скажем
так потому что когда ты управляешь
несколькими бизнесами наверно ты уже
перетекает в сторону больше бизнесмена
ты должен понимать как
управлять этими это целый портфель да у
тебя то должны их балансировать должно
помогать им выходить на новые рынки
должен думать о скажем так на
перспективу но цель была во первых
наверное
определить что у меня есть из активов
что из них плохие активы активы что из
них плохие то хорошее активы и научиться
правильно распределять эти активы в
разные портфеле чтобы достичь свои
определенные виссона цели
[музыка]
добро пожаловать на наш возмущен
инвестиции это только про долгосрочное
планирование
то есть когда мы говорим инвестиции
здесь важно понимать что
психотип инвестора он кардинально
отличается психотипа спекулянта
инвестиция первую очередь это про
фундаментальные цену
спекулятивная это она ничего общего
вашего на ментальность не иметь как
правило это
попытка найти статистические там
паттерны подключичной периоды считается
что инвестор это другая профессия а
предпринимает это другая профессия и я
думаю на таком инвест темпе как минимум
части участников этот буткемп показал то
что они не инвесторы вообще и это
наверно тоже здорово потому что часто
предприниматель хочет усидеть на двух
стульях одновременно и он думает если у
меня хорошо получается в бизнесе то
возможна такая же вероятность что я и
буду хорошим инвестора это большое
заблуждение и как раз
часть предпринимателей с кем не общался
они действительно говорили что лучше я
доверю с экспертом теперь я однозначно
для себя понял что инвестирование меня я
считаю что это тоже классно на что
человек больше не тратит энергию думаю
что он супер герой или там не знаю
красавчик там том круз он года я не стоя
есть я предприниматель и инвестор и это
здорово современная теория инвестиций
строится на портфельного управления
очень важно управлять рисками упали
очень важно управлять своим активными
соответственно современной принципе
этапе очень диверсификация то есть
долгосрочное планирование то есть это
инвестиции это планирование не но и всю
жизнь и поэтому
для предпринимателя это очень важно
потому что предприниматели у них как
правило высокая концентрация риска на
своем бизнесе также есть поведенческие
аспекты то есть как правило они имеют
высокую эмоциональный привязку к своему
бизнесу и соответственно для них важно с
него стекаться она как бы самая острая
было посеяно управления то есть целом
как бы управление капитала предполагает
первую очередь это девиз стекаться то
есть это это инвестиции максимально
широкий набор инструментов
которые с целью там девочек там чтоб
чтобы была исцелена
и минимизации рисков максимизация дохода
на и я нагнулся риска очень важные роль
играет именно поведенческие аспекты
поведенческих финансов с поведенческие
финансы это очень важная наука то есть
несколько людей получили уже могольской
премий по поведенческим финансам и на
самом деле
современная портфельная теория то оценка
моделировании компании обязательно этот
процесс включатели не только понимание
традиционных и нас в и комбинация
поведенческих финансов и поэтому вот
именно важность
не просто понимать но и рефлексировать
это вот это важную часть тогда и и к
сожалению мы люди и поэтому мы не можем
просто об этом знать как они
недостаточно нужно постоянно бы хан
рефлексировать то есть постоянно это
процесс
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
инвестиционную декларацию вы можете
вставлять все что вы хотите все что
хотите это могут заметки и там черновики
идеей можете должна дописывать ничего
страшного риск это двигатель процесса но
делать и обуздан а правильно и управляем
[музыка]
как марк твен все время сказал покупайте
землю насколько мне известно ее бывший
не производят на самом деле повышение
цен на бензин и нефть это следствие не
до инвестирования в нефтедобычу и не до
инвестирования в нпз
[музыка]
мне очень понравилось что наши учителя
эксперты это были проверены и главное
мур бланк или вещам специалисты потому
что как он отзывался о них какие кисы
они решали для него это для меня был
хороший показатель когда я рассказала о
своём старт-апе мне уже подсказали дали
на водку и уже дали контакт с которым я
должна связаться то есть я уже
почувствовала результат вот этого над
working а спикер и узнайте они мне
понравятся именно тем что нет вот этой
вот чисто педагогической работы они явно
практики и которые дают советы именно из
своего жизненного опыта в
профессиональной деятельности инсайтов
очень было много очень много ну сложно
что-то вот отдельно выделить потому что
практически все пять дней сплошные сайты
да я получал знания не только от
экспертов которые пришли до а также от
тех людей которые делились своим опытом
а где-то подсказывали мне например ирина
дала просто крутую для меня фишку я
говорил о том что хотел бы создать там
фонд рассказывала его формах и так далее
но говорил что это для меня такая
сложная задача я на вам каким-то таким
простым инсайтом развеяла весь этот
туман все прошел шикарно мне понравился
материал не
агрессивный материал вам был подготовлен
очень четко со всеми элементами в
принципе мы ознакомились со всеми
базовыми азами инвестирование и разных
рынков
[музыка]